SPEAKER 1: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming to our Authors
at Google series.
Today we're pleased to present
Dr. Mark Schoen who's here to
talk about his latest book
called "Your Survival Instinct
is Killing You.
Retrain your Brain to Conquer
Fear, Make Better Decisions,
and Thrive In the 21st Century."
The book contains
strategies and ideas that show
you how to build your
instinctual muscles for
survival and managing
discomfort.
Dr. Schoen is an Assistant
Clinical Professor of Medicine
at the UCLA Geffen School of
Medicine, where he teaches
courses to medical students
on performance and
decision-making under pressure,
as well as hypnosis
and medicine.
He has extensively studied the
area of performance under
pressure, particularly as it
relates to physical and mental
decision-making.
His work has been featured
extensively on
television and radio.
And we're happy to have
him here today.
Please welcome Dr. Schoen.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
DR. MARC SCHOEN:
Good afternoon.
One question to start out.
What is the one thing that we
can do to influence our
health, influence our happiness,
to influence
performance, to influence
aging, to influence
relationships?
What's the one thing?
AUDIENCE: Breathe.
DR. MARC SCHOEN: And it's
not quitting your job
and moving to Tahiti.
AUDIENCE: Spend more time with
our friends and family.
DR. MARC SCHOEN: Friends
and family.
Someone said breathe.
You know what it is?
The right answer is taming
our survival instinct.
Yes, could something like
our survival instinct be
influencing all those different
parts of our life?
The quick answer is you bet.
The survival instinct we know
is supposed to be about
survival, isn't it?
It's supposed to help
us survive.
But in fact, it's putting
us in harm's way.
Let's talk about it.
What is the survival instinct?
It's a part of the brain.
Many of us know it because it's
the part of the brain
that clicks on the fight or
flight part of us, the part of
us that gets mobilized to help
us get out of danger.
And sometimes we experience it
feeling really flushed in the
body, right?
Rapid heartbeat, quick
breathing, the mine getting
really obsessive, the body
getting tingly, sweating.
In other cases, we just
feel worked up.
But the survival Instinct meant
to keep us out of danger
is now 24/7 on.
It was never meant
to be on 24/7.
It was meant to help us when
we are in danger--
real danger, real physical
danger, like in the early days
running from a spear of an
opposing tribe or running from
a saber-toothed tiger.
Now I don't know about you.
When I think back, when I
think way back, I can't
remember last time I
was running from a
saber-toothed tiger.
Most the time I'm running
from myself.
And that's true of most
of our danger today
is at our own hands.
And yeah, it's not real
danger, isn't it?
Getting cut off on the freeway,
having to stand in
line, someone hurting
our feelings--
are these real situations
to evoke this kind
of reaction in us?
The fact is it's staying on, and
it was never meant to be
this chronic.
But it is.
Now think, for example, have you
noticed that when you're
more worked up, more revved
up, does it affect your
performance?
Does it affect your ability
to make decisions?
Or do you notice when you worked
up like this, are you
more obsessive, think about
things, worry more?
Generally worry about things
that probably will never even
happen, Right
Or how about sleep?
Does it affect our sleep?
Do we sleep less?
Or our sleep is impaired or
compromised, unsettled?
Do we eat more?
Do we drink more?
Do we smoke more?
Don't answer that question.
So we can see it affects
us in a profound way.
So let's look at what
is the chemistry.
What is going on that's making
this survival instinct happen?
The best way to think about it
is to look at our different
parts of our brain.
We actually have three parts to
our brain, but we're only
going to talk about two.
One is a part of the brain
that has existed since we
broke away from reptiles.
And it is called the limbic
brain, and it's the part of
the brain that has to do
with gut responses--
hunger, pain, sleep,
fear, anger,
pleasure, visceral responses.
We have another part
of our brain--
I call the cerebral brain--
it's the logical part
of the brain.
It's where all the problem
solving gets done, the
decision making gets done.
It's the part that can be
thinking about oh, I better do
this this time, rather
than that.
Or last time, this was the
result, so I need to do this
differently.
It's the part that we rely
significantly on.
And these two different
parts to the brain are
jockeying for position.
The cerebral brain wants to
control those visceral drives.
This role, gut part of the brain
wants full expression of
those drives.
It wants it right away.
So they're at odds.
They actually speak two
different languages.
It's almost like if you ever
had a tantrumming child and
you tried to tell the child
logically that's really not a
good idea for you
to be so upset.
Would the child listen?
Most likely not.
Because the cerebral brain
speaks this language trying to
be logical to this more
emotional brain,
it doesn't get it.
So they don't always
get along.
But the survival instinct is
housed in this limbic brain.
It's a part of the brain
that's all about
one thing, one goal--
to keep us out of danger.
And it's absolute.
There's no grades.
We either are or
not in danger.
And so now, more than ever
before, we as a society are
much more revved up.
It's taking less to trigger
us, isn't it?
Have you noticed things
that might have been
inconsequential before in our
past are enough to set us off.
Why?
Why should this be happening?
Don't we live in a society
filled with all sorts of
wonderful technological
comforts and advances?
Don't we?
But guess what?
As we are filled with all these
advances that make our
lives so much more comfortable,
we have become
less tolerant of being
uncomfortable.
Our comfort zone has shrunken.
And the result of it shrinking
is that we're feeling
uncomfortable a lot
more often.
And what's the significance
of that?
Huge.
Because this survival instinct,
the part of us
that's supposed to keep us out
of danger, when it feels
uncomfortable, it senses that
we're uncomfortable inside.
It doesn't think about it oh,
you know, just because you're
standing in line or you're
stuck in traffic.
No, it thinks one thing.
Thinks I'm in danger.
So now the more uncomfortable we
are in our lives, the more
this signal's going off saying
we're in danger.
And when that happens,
it clicks on
the survival instinct.
It stays on, goes into
overdrive, and we
become maxed out.
And what are the results?
What are the results of this?
Huge.
Depression, anxiety, inability
to sleep, pain.
They're just going
through the roof.
Now isn't this odd that this
should be happening?
We are living in a society
with tremendous amount of
resources for health, not only
medicine, but research that we
can read, people given
us tools--
self-help.
It's everywhere.
But why are all these symptoms
getting worse?
We are missing something.
We're missing something.
Something has to be
done differently.
And so we're talking about
feeling uncomfortable.
So a key part of this, again,
is that when we're
uncomfortable, it signals
danger to the brain.
And then it turns on the
survival instinct, and we are
revved up and worked
up and react.
Now you might think is that
really that significant?
Is it not a problem that
we're more revved up?
Think of it.
Think of it this way that what
we're basically running on
long-term is leaded fuel,
running coal.
We're not running cleanly.
And believe me, this is why we
are seeing symptoms like this
shoot through the roof.
And it it's not just
in adults.
It's not just young adults.
I'm now seeing this in kids as
young as eight years old.
And I never saw that happen
30 years ago.
The symptoms I'm seeing in kids
like migraines, horrible
stomach problems, inability to
take exams, panic attacks.
This didn't happen in
eight-year-olds 30 years ago.
It happened in young adults.
So it's filtered all the way
down through society.
So what is it?
What is one of the factors
that's influencing us?
I call it agitance.
Agitance to me is how sped up we
are, how activated we are,
how hot we're running inside.
It's sort of like an internal
thermostat, using this
metaphorically.
And so that as we get
more sped up,
the temperature rises.
We're all accustomed to
being 98.6, right?
That's the norm.
Those who are meditators
probably have a lower body
temperature.
I've been doing hypnosis
since I've been 13.
Mine's about 96.
So we have this temperature,
and the higher that we get
revved up, the higher
levels of agitance,
the hotter we get.
Now it gets to a certain point,
when this speed gets
high enough, it crosses what I
call a discomfort threshold.
And as it speeds up, goes up,
it crosses that threshold.
We feel uncomfortable--
clicks on the survival
instinct.
Now it's really important to
think of this agitance.
It's not like stress which
is bad or negative.
Agitance can even
be a good thing.
First symptoms I ever got
from stress in my life
was when I was 36.
And I was loving it.
I was loving what I was doing,
running two cutting-edge
programs, one on how the
mind affects the body.
I was loving what I was doing.
But I started getting
symptoms.
So this agitance isn't
just bad things.
It can be good things.
That's why it's different
than stress.
Stress is something
very discrete--
a conflict with a boss or
coworker, or having to meet a
certain deadline.
This agitance is just
generalized speed in the body.
So what affects it?
What affects agitance then?
Well, one is our constant need
for sensory stimulation.
We all know about
that, don't we?
How many of us just sit
and read a book.
How many of us just
talk to a person.
Most of us are engaging in
a flood of stimulation.
I was at a Laker Game a few
years ago, and they were
actually winning.
And it was a playoff game.
The tickets cost hundreds
of dollars.
And I decide I'm looking around
the audience while the
game is going on.
And everywhere I can
see, people were on
their phones texting.
No one's paying attention
to the game.
It wasn't enough stimulation.
And we have become accustomed
to needing lots of
stimulation.
We didn't want to just
talk to someone.
We want to talk to someone.
We want to watch something.
We want to eat at
the same time.
We want to play with
our phones.
We have become addicted
to stimulation.
We have.
And you know what?
It has a physiological effect.
It's related to dopamine in
the brain, which is a
neurotransmitter.
It's a biochemical that
affects mood.
And the more distant stimulation
we get, the more
we become addicted to
this dopamine surge.
And after a while, the
stimulation stops producing as
much dopamine.
And we got to do more
stimulation to get back to it.
The next area is what I call
instant gratification, the
need for something now.
We're hungry.
We want to eat, don't we?
We don't want to wait.
Hey, if we need an
answer, and we're
uncertain, where do we go?
You guys only get one choice
in this place.
Pass or fail on this one.
Where do you go if you're
uncertain about something?
Google, yes.
That's the pitch for Google.
But so we've learned to not
live with uncertainty.
When I was writing my
dissertation and looking to
find resources to supply my
dissertation, I had to go up
and down these stacks of the
library looking for something.
And of course, I'd get to the
upper stacks with a--
I knew that this would be the
article that would be just the
one I needed.
And of course, I'd get there,
and it would be gone.
It wouldn't be there.
So I I'd have to wait
days to get it.
We don't do that
anymore, do we?
We want it right away.
And that leads to the other
thing that influences agitance
We've become impatient,
haven't we?
We get really irritated if we
have to stand in line, if we
have to ask the same question
twice, if we have to send the
same email twice.
We want an email response
quickly, don't we?
We want a text message
quickly.
Who wants to wait?
And what about perfection?
We have become a culture
that wants perfection.
Why?
Because the computer model--
everything's perfect,
isn't it?
Everything lines up.
You either get it right,
or you get it wrong.
But the problem is the world
doesn't line up perfectly.
And so we take this scheme in
which we're all working and
apply it to the real world.
It creates disastrous results in
our relationships, because
the world seldom produces
exactly what we expect.
All these factors of agitance
pump up our level of
discomfort.
They really do.
They cross that discomfort
threshold, and we start
getting worked up.
So it requires a very little
provocation to set us off--
very, very little.
But let's talk about some
specific things-- how this
really happens.
Let's take performance
and decision
making under pressure.
Happens to be one of
my great interest.
It's a class that I teach at
UCLA in the Medical School
where we take students and
groom them through these
series of exercises and
trainings, so that when
they're under pressure,
they perform at
their absolute best.
So what is it about pressure
that's important?
Pressure is experienced by the
brain as uncomfortable.
And what's most of our
experiences of pressure and
performance?
It began when we were
young, right?
Oral presentations, playing
school sports, and learning
like oh my god, I have to do
well this next time or when I
get up and do an oral
presentation, I don't want to
embarrass myself or forget
what I'm supposed to say.
And most of us have had
some bad experiences.
And those bad experiences
prejudice us in the present.
So what happens?
Now, when we're under pressure,
it has all those old
associations of flopping, being
embarrassed, being rejected.
So now when we're under pressure
now, we want to
change that.
But look what happens.
When the pressure goes up,
we get uncomfortable.
The survival instinct goes on.
Here's what happens
mechanically.
When the survival instinct goes
on, it diverts the blood
supply, the oxygen,
away from that
cerebral part of our brain.
That's the part of the brain
where the decision making is,
the problem solving is.
So it just diverts the
blood away, turns on
the fight or flight.
And since the cerebral brain
processes information so much
slower than the limbic brain,
it can't stop it.
How many people have
noticed this?
Has this ever happened to you
when you felt your heart
beating, where all of a sudden,
you felt worked up.
And you weren't sure why.
And then you had to
think about it.
Why am I upset?
That's because the limbic
brain is quicker.
It's faster, but it
had to be, right?
If someone was throwing a spear
at us, would we want to
sit back and think?
Hmm, should I hang out?
Or should I run?
We didn't want to do that,
so we needed to process
information instantaneously
when we were in danger.
So this limbic brain
has priority.
So when that does, it takes the
blood supply away from the
cerebral brain where the problem
solving happens.
And the result is it just
doesn't have enough juice to
run the machinery.
It's kind of like a electrical
power grid, an electrical
power grid that gets overtapped
and there isn't
enough energy to go around.
So lights start going out
all over the place.
And one of those lights is in
this problem solving area.
And when it happens, what
happens to our decisions?
They become defensive
in nature.
In other words, we're more
concerned about the our losses
than we are about advancing
our gains.
And even we have situations in
front of us, we will perceive
negative outcomes, even when
a positive outcome
might be more likely.
So as you can see, our
performance is
dramatically affected.
But think about this.
You all probably work
tons of hours.
And you're given a lot of
demands that you have to meet.
And the younger generation has
had much more of this jumping
through hoops.
And you have to learn more.
But who teaches you how to
execute that knowledge?
Who teaches you how to take
that knowledge and make it
happen under extreme
conditions?
I never got that training.
I remember playing sports,
and I used to pitch.
I used to remember thinking
like all this practice.
I just hope to God when I get
in the game, I can get the
ball over the plate.
It was like total random.
No one teaches us how to
perform under pressure.
And to me, that's equally as
important as the information.
But it's not being done.
Just think if we could learn how
to perform under pressure,
what kind of edge that
would get us.
When I wrote my book, I
interviewed different people
who are big in business and who
did well under pressure.
And you know what
they told me?
They told me this.
They said you know what, because
I can do well under
fire, I have an edge over my
competition who folds and
unravels under pressure.
And they said that they
particularly liked dealing
with the younger generation,
because they're even less
trained in dealing with pressure
and being under fire.
So this is something
we need to do.
This is something that is part
of my training is teaching
people how to do that, how to
teach companies, employees,
executives, students to
be able to do that.
So important.
But the good news--
very important-- is that this
is something we can learn.
This is something you can
be trained to do.
No doubt some people
are better at it.
But it doesn't mean that the
rest of us can't improve
significantly, for sure.
Now the other area of my
studying and research is in
the area of health.
What is the effect
of this survival
instinct on our health?
It's huge.
When we are running at this
higher speed, what it does
when it creates the fear, it
triggers a process called
inflammation.
How many people have heard
of inflammation.
A small portion?
Inflammation is perhaps the
leading theory of aging,
disease, health.
Inflammation is intended
for a good thing.
It's to basically beef up the
immune soldiers of the body so
they can fight infection.
But what happens is when we're
under stress, fear, anger, we
beef up more immune soldiers
than what we need.
What's the effect?
It's the effect of having a
bunch of Marines Brigade in
the bleachers all
drinking beer.
What's the end result?
A fight.
A fight's going to happen.
And where does that
fight happen?
It happens within us.
And these immune soldiers,
instead of fighting pathogens,
they start chewing on and
chomping on our organs.
And we age a lot faster.
We can control inflammation.
One of my earlier things
that I've done--
in fact, I even just published
a study showing that we can
change that inflammatory
response in the body in a
simple way.
OK, so if it can have this
profound effect on
performance, decision making, on
health, relationships, what
do we do to improve things?
Now you could say to me
hey, you know what?
This agitance stuff
is here to stay.
And you might be right.
Maybe we all have to just
get accustomed to
running a lot faster.
Maybe all the stimulation
is not going to change.
Maybe instant gratification's
not going to change.
Perfection.
You may say that.
And you may be arguably
right on that point.
So if that's not going to
change, and we're all going to
be running a lot faster, that
means we're going to all be a
lot more uncomfortable,
doesn't it?
So then we have one
choice, don't we?
One choice.
The choices to retrain our
instincts to being
uncomfortable, to make it so
that when we're uncomfortable
it does not mean danger.
Think we can do it?
Can we retrain our instincts?
Yes, we can.
We most definitely can.
A moment ago, I referred to a
study that just got published.
It took people who reacted with
this kind of agitance and
discomfort and stress and seeing
if we can recondition
it, so that when they're under
stress, they don't physically
react to it.
I'd taken blood measures.
I was able to show that, in
fact, we can do that.
So then what do we do?
First goal is this.
We accept that we're not trying
to banish discomfort.
We're not trying to
get rid of it.
Because you know what?
It's not going away.
It's here to stay.
But many people believe that the
goal is to get rid of it.
And contemporary thought, in
terms of managing stress, what
is that about?
Trying to stop stresses, trying
to not feel it or to
distract ourselves from it.
But what happens?
That which we avoid
becomes what?
Bigger!
Becomes larger, becomes more
of a threat, doesn't it?
So many times, our attempt to
control stress, fear, is
making us more vulnerable.
We don't want to do that.
We want to change the brain's
reaction to being
uncomfortable.
And a sophisticated way to do
it, based on the newest data,
is literally to train the brain
so when we're doing
something frightening,
uncomfortable, instead of
going straight to the fear
center, like a one lane road
to the fear center, we want
to make it take roads to
different parts of the brain
that have no association, no
connection to fear.
And by doing that, we dilute the
power of that fear center.
It's very elaborate,
sophisticated, and fascinating
reading and something everyone
can learn to do.
But since we don't have enough
time to go into that, and you
can certainly dive into
that at a later time--
my writings--
but I would like to talk about
some things before I stop that
you can do.
One, if you want to try lowering
the agitance levels,
think about what I call chilling
out before bedtime.
Yeah.
Most people go high gear--
right?-- all
the way up to bedtime.
Boom, switch gears, say OK,
it's time to go to sleep.
But sleep is not the
same as relaxation.
And so even though we may fall
asleep, we're still tense and
worked up on the inside.
If you chill out before bedtime,
it has an enormous
effect on physical symptoms the
next day, like grinding
your teeth, headaches,
stomachaches, other types of
aches, your mood--
important.
Or take a technological
time out.
Oh, I just realized it's
not the place to
say that, is that?
But I guess I've made the
mistake, so I probably won't
be asked again to come back.
But it's true.
We need to take some more
breaks from technology,
particularly before bedtime.
An hour, two hours, before
bedtime makes a huge
difference.
Now let's say you wanted to
improve your discomfort
muscle, so you could
handle more
discomfort than you do now.
Build up that muscle
that's atrophying--
what can you do?
One of the ones that I like
is called expanding
your comfort zone.
For some that may be taking
a new route to work.
It may mean not using Google
Maps to got there or maybe
using Apple maps.
We want to do something that
challenges us, particularly
something that may
be comfortable.
Doing something that we
might have failed at
before or not succeeded.
I like to tell people to go take
an acting class, do an
improv class, sing, do these
kind of presentations.
Put yourself in the position
where you're uncomfortable and
where you can survive.
Very, very important.
I am getting the signal that
it's time to stop talking.
But the bottom line I want you
to keep in mind here is that
these are all things
that we can learn.
This is not something that's
not obtainable.
True, some people are better
at it than others.
But the fact is we
can all learn it.
There's data to show we can
learn it, and get a
lot better at it.
And so rather than being
something to avoid and fear--
being uncomfortable--
it's something that you can
embrace and find, in fact,
that it can facilitate
performance,
rather than be an obstacle.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
DR. MARC SCHOEN: And if there
are any questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I was wondering is
this agitance concept that
you talk about, is this
something that you can
actually measure?
Like do we have biochemical
markers for it or
anything like that?
DR. MARC SCHOEN: Yeah, the way
you would really measure it is
look at some
psycho-physiological measures.
You would look at body heat.
You would look at respiration
levels, the breathing.
You'd look at heartbeat.
You could measure tension
in the body.
You can use electrodes on
particularly the forehead.
And you can also look at brain
rhythms, which would be more
rapid than slow.
AUDIENCE: So that sounds like
it's at least slightly
complicated, but I guess my
follow-on question was going
to be is this something that
we could do a longitudinal
study on and say is
this actually
getting worse over time?
Are we more amped up now
than we used to be?
DR. MARC SCHOEN: Absolutely.
We are so much more amped
up than we used to.
And that's why I was giving
the example of why should
eight-year-olds be having
these problems
of blocking on exams?
Why should they be having
headaches, stomachaches?
Because now at an early age,
everyone's under more pressure.
I remember when my kids
were younger.
They're having to do a couple
hours of homework a night,
when they were seven.
It's ridiculous.
And so because we're so much
more amped up, and there's so
much more sensory stimulation,
and we're so much more about
instant gratification, it
is just sky-rocketing.
So yes, it is much worse than
it ever used to be.
AUDIENCE: The thought I had, I
recently read Jared Diamond's
latest book, and he talks
about how traditional
societies, like what they're
like, how they
deal with their problems.
And the thought that came to
me is that I'm not entirely
convinced that this agitation
factor is what's increasing.
Because reading about these
other societies, they sound
terribly agitated
all the time.
Like they're worried about
people stabbing them.
They're worried about their
friends murdering them,
starving to death, all these
typical problems that--
we have other agitators but
humanity has persistently
dealt with agitators all the
time and at a very high level
of all the time.
But what I imagine is the reason
kids these days are
having these problems that you
mention is that we're not
dealing with them, with social
mechanisms that these other
societies have adopted.
What kind of like social
interactions would you think
would help when dealing
with each other?
Because you suggested go do
something that agitates you.
Take
an acting Class.
But just doing that is good,
but what do you do after
you're done with the
acting class and
you're still agitated?
You have to get some sort of
social interaction to relieve
that agitation, learn that
you're OK, and build up that
muscle but says bad things
happen, then you're OK.
DR. MARC SCHOEN:
Great question.
Excellent question.
And because I've had limited
time, I couldn't expand on it.
But you're absolutely right.
The goal isn't just to
create agitation.
The goal is to change
how we label, how we
experience that agitation.
There's actually a part in the
brain that straddles the old
and new brain.
And its job is to interpret our
physical experience inside.
Because the physiology of being
stressed out and fearful
is not necessarily different
than the physiology of being
happy and excited.
But there's a part of the brain
that interprets that
physiology as bad or
as OK or good.
So what we want to do is train
ourselves that this type of
discomfort actually
is beneficial.
Now, the elaborate way in my
writings, I show that what we
can do is take this kind of
agitation and recondition the
brain to react differently.
And one way actually is to
use a social component.
One very fascinating way which I
use in my classes is to take
this, create an agitation,
create a stress, but do it in
a group of people.
So now, first of all, there's
pressure to perform
in a group of people.
And it creates a vulnerability,
because you
know you're going to either fail
or succeed in your peers.
But the group process actually
stimulates our
hormones in the body.
A thing called oxytocin.
You've probably heard of it.
It's this good feeling
hormone.
And so what happens
is-- it happens to
both men and women--
is that now they're in a
vulnerable situation, feeling
pressure, in this
group situation,
which creates a bonding.
These hormones are released
in the body.
And so now it gets associated
in the brain with a warmer,
positive, connected feeling.
So we're teaching you that
of vulnerability, of
transparency, rather than of
perfection, being uptight,
being angry, being fearful,
that a transparency of
vulnerability actually creates
a good feeling.
That's how we start doing it.
Great question.
AUDIENCE: We all know stress is
bad, but can we ignore the
fact that stress is also the
main reason for one of our
motivation to do something?
If we suppress our stress, are
we going to be more passive?
DR. MARC SCHOEN: Now I want to
make sure I got the question.
Is the question is that
we use stress to
ignite us, as a catalyst?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DR. MARC SCHOEN: And then
if we take it away,
the question was?
AUDIENCE: Are we going
to be more passive?
DR. MARC SCHOEN: Ah.
The goal is not to
take away stress.
The goal isn't to take away
being uncomfortable.
It's never going to
happen, because
the world isn't perfect.
It never lines up.
Or if it does line
up perfectly, how
long does it last?
It's transitory.
So most the time, the world
doesn't line up perfectly.
And so we really need to be
effective at dealing with a
world that's constantly changing
and not perfect.
So, no, the goal isn't to banish
stress or discomfort.
The goal is OK, if discomfort
is here to stay, we got to
manage it well.
And if we manage it well, it
facilitates performance.
It doesn't lead to
an apathy at all.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if
meditation help, and what kind
of meditation will help?
DR. MARC SCHOEN: Yes, the
question is about meditation.
And meditation is wonderful.
There's plenty of research on
meditation having a very
helpful effect on the
brain, on the body.
One of the things that
meditation can do--
mindful meditation is the one
I'm most familiar with--
is that it creates a better
balance between this emotional
limbic brain and the
cerebral brain.
So it brings them into
better balance.
The problem--
what happens is that as we
become uncomfortable or
experience trauma, it
destabilizes the brain.
So that often this limbic
emotional brain is the one
that has hold of the steering
wheel, and it's the one
driving the car.
But meditation, and the one I
believe a lot in is hypnosis,
can bring both these parts
of the brain back
into a balance state.
But mindful meditation is
the one that has the
most data on it.
AUDIENCE: Beyond behavioral
therapy, like CBT or DBT, is
there other stuff from
psychology that can be used to
attenuate the agitance?
DR. MARC SCHOEN: Yes.
I believe that where this field
is going, I believe that
this is the future.
The future is we're not just
going to be sitting around
talking and trying to come up
with strategies and cognitive
and intellectual ways of doing
something or taking a bunch of
deep breaths.
I think where it's really
going is how can we take
specific parts of the brain and
change how those brains
parts fire.
That's what we want to do.
And I think to look around for
treatments that actually focus
directly on the fear center.
Incidentally, I should
tell you this--
I forgot to mention--
if any of you are interested in
a certain breath technique
I developed for this approach,
for my approaches, it's not
set up on my website yet, but if
you wanted to email me, I'm
happy to send it to you free
of charge, of course.
My email is my name--
marcschoenphd@gmail.com.
And just put in the subject line
"breath technique" and
I'll send it to you.
So going back to your question
of what kind of approaches, I
would suggest look for these
newer approaches that really
target these specific
areas of the brain.
I think it's just quicker, more
direct, and ultimately
more powerful and
more enduring.
OK?
Thank you very much.
Appreciate your interest.